so basically say what you think is
interesting for yourself uh pursue
novelty
and if it interests you it will interest
a significant portion of the audience so
this kind of knows forget the audience
or it won't
don't pay don't yeah don't pay attention
to the audience don't right right
followers if you're speaking for the
audience the audience is worthless if
you're writing for followers your
followers are worthless
think about any other sport like think
about a sport do they play for their
audience no
they play to win that is literally the
only reason they're on the field is to
win
and so like i the if you want these
people to play the best you you you put
them in a bubble with no audience
so most of us here in this audience have
listened to your podcast
and it's been wildly successful what do
you think drives the success of the
podcast
i think the podcast is successful
because
i
i knew i had a guaranteed audience of
one and that means i was scratching my
own itch
in the case of
whenever i try to design something for a
market
it fails whenever i just do something
that i couldn't find for myself then it
does fine it seems to be the trend so
i'm scratching my own itch if you have a
guaranteed market of one i.e yourself
like you're ahead of 99 of the
entrepreneurs out there right
yeah i think the audience is also
inauthentic and people even though
the people will deep down detect that
someone who's playing to the audience
will eventually be boring to the
audience
yeah that i really enjoy that i really
like that framework that resonates part
of it also thinks just the authenticity
of having a conversation with a buddy
like you guys referring to
it's also about risk i think like if
it's it's risky to talk about the things
that are in your head and you haven't
talked about them before you haven't
performed them hundreds and hundreds of
times like when you're when you're
reading a script and there's obviously
this is a spectrum so you can have
things you've never talked about you
have to think you know you have your
bits that you go to i think it's
actually very similar to sort of
stand-up comedy uh but it's i think it's
about the risk it's about the fact this
is why live performance is interesting
even though you can go listen to an
album and it's higher quality you have
to go to a music festival uh is because
you're like it's it's the risk involved
uh and you know
yeah it's hard to be interesting for
long periods of time uh most people
cannot speak extemporaneously on many
topics and synthesize them on the fly as
robbie was saying and julian was saying
these are these are difficult talents so
what ends up happening is most people
when they have to go live they end up
resorting to talking about politics news
weather sports because these are things
that are also live so there's always
some you can always say the old things
again in a new way about new data so
talk radio tends to degenerate into
those categories but now if you get out
of those categories what remains if you
want someone to just talk
extemporaneously live there are very
very few people who can do that for long
periods of time and stay interesting
right most uh most of the few remaining
ones you'll find are in comedy and even
those are heavily rehearsed right a good
comedian rehearses their jokes over and
over but a good comedian is a good
speaker they're witty what are they
doing they're telling the truth the
uncomfortable truth in a way that they
can get away with it right they're
showing how to be brave in front of an
audience and not get you know hit by the
mob it's a classic role the gesture and
so
um you know it's hard to be interesting
for a long period of time and most most
people can't do it so you end up with
professional comedians being the very
small class that can do it now so if you
look at talk radio you know there's a
howard sterns of the world which are
basically comedians uh there and joe
rogan right there's the um the news
people of the world are very often in
extreme politics right so they always
think you talk about rush limbaugh who
just recently passed away with one of
these characters or you have
sportscasters
but outside of that talk radio is really
tough so clubhouse house clubhouse
trying to tackle that well one thing
clubhouse does is it throws multiple
people in a room right uh second is it's
on schedule like i don't have a naval
show i don't have to like show up at a
specific time and always perform i can
leave when i'm bored or i can turn over
the heavy lifting to silence somebody
else
sahil actually called me into this room
which is why i'm here
and so uh there there are there are ways
to kind of mitigate status games that
was the status game right there
this format is hilarious because the
moment i come in my followers get
notified that my followers show up some
of them stick to you so of course you
want me in your room because i still
gain a whole host of followers right
that you then leech off of so what have
you done for me lately style
i'm working on an angelus rolling yeah
everybody
but you know i i show up because sahel
is interesting to talk to right he's one
of the few people that i can drift with
for long periods of time and he'll say
something interesting i might learn
something
that i get a kick out of so here i am
it's a bait right you set the bait here
i am but even even joe rogan joe rogan
is a stand-up comedian he's a really
funny guy he's a really interesting guy
he's got lots of opinions everything but
even joe doesn't make the joe rogan
podcast about joe rogan he's
interviewing people because at some
point you just run out of things to talk
about so you need somebody else to riff
with and so i just think the clubhouse
phenomenon's gonna be interesting now
there are a few people in human history
who can just talk and talk and talk on
their own about whatever their favorite
topic is and they will inspire lots of
people there aren't many of those people
but those are the people that create
movements right gandhi martin luther
king hitler uh strong people who are
trump yeah these are people who can rift
extemporaneously for long periods of
time and their audience who is aligned
with them will forgive the foibles
understand the broader message and then
get really really unified behind this
person so i think those kinds of leaders
for better or for worse will emerge in
clubhouse and sort of be the dominant
personalities over time they will
literally have individual cults of
personality
yeah if you thought donald trump was
scary on
on twitter imagine clubhouse
i'm interested in what makes something
interesting and i think part of it is
novelty like neval was mentioning
earlier so if you break down novelty it
seems to be a few things
one is did you say something counter
narrative so something against what
people are told is how the world works
or maybe something counter-intuitive you
know something's the effect of like oh
[ __ ] i have no idea that's how the world
works i didn't realize that intuitively
or is it shock and awe uh or is it a
really elegant synthesis maybe so i
think i think it's all all of those
things are the same thing which is truth
it's telling the truth either a truth
that people didn't already know or it's
the truth they knew but couldn't
articulate the right way or it's a truth
that they did know could articulate but
we're too afraid to say it's all about
truth
it is very difficult
to speak truth
in front of a large group of people and
it takes a lot of verbal skill and a lot
of synthesis to do it and yes you can
teach them something new but eventually
run out of new things so then a lot of
it becomes about articulating old things
in new ways like what is wisdom right
wisdom
cannot be communicated it's something
that has to be learned on your own has
to be experienced and you synthesize it
for yourself knowledge
you know we can collectively build
knowledge if you figure out how to build
an airplane then i can take your
schematics and build the next airplane
and improve upon it but if i figure out
you know how to have a good love life
and that comes after lots of bad
relationships i can't pass that on to
you you have to figure that out for
yourself so wisdom has to be
rediscovered by people one at a time
that said what i can do is i can remind
you of things that you already know and
the best way to do that is to get past
cliches because cliches are things
you've heard too often and i can
re-articulate something that i've
learned in a new way so it strikes at
the core of yourself and reminds you
that aha yes i should keep that in mind
thank you for re-articulating that for
me and so
there
that is something you can get rewarded
for which is communicating truths but
these are truths that have to be learned
individually
and you can only be reminded of but can
be re-articulated so all the three
points you made i think fall under the
category of truth
yeah that resonates so something like
truth plus authenticity and not giving a
[ __ ] about the audience there's
something there and there's one word
well they all all go together if you're
if you well the truth is the ultimate
yeah if you're not if you if you care
what the audience thinks then you're
pandering to them which means you're
saying things you don't necessarily
believe to get a certain reaction to the
audience and that's falsehood yeah so so
my twitter account like the reason it
works
is because i post the gumroad financials
every month
all the other tweets are fine and fun
but i think the reason that i have i
have real skin in the game because
that's the only thing that matters
that's the thing that people judge me
for am i running a successful business
or not like that would change bro that
would change everything about me for the
reason i'm not you know my identity i'm
fine don't worry about it
but for other people and for the status
game that's the thing that really
matters uh and i think it it is it just
always goes back to it's it's about
truth and it's about taking risks it's
it's about you know you you you
acknowledge you you have to find the
truth to sort of succeed after you take
the risk but it's just about making bets
and then succeeding in public i think
people talk about building in public all
the time that's not what's important
what's important is succeeding in public
uh yeah
i don't think that's true i i i know
that's your perception of why you think
you might have credibility but i don't
think that's true at all
um i
i think feel free to tell me why my
tweets are better than i think
no yeah your tweets stand on their own
they're good tweets you know you know
some of them are derivative of mine so i
forgive that um you did come after me on
twitter so i dragged all this stuff
early well i mean i came in early and
time stamped all the good stuff so
everyone else looked through they're so
fine um but yeah so some of them are
derivative uh some of them are obvious
but you have some really good tweets you
have a lot of tweets that make me stop
and think
um and not a lot of people on twitter do
that
and you know there's a lot of wisdom in
your tweets it comes from your pain i
knew you when you were young and
insufferable
you didn't have much interesting to say
a lot of technical things to say but you
know much wisdom to you it's only when
gumroad almost died and you suffered
over it um that you gained the wisdom
and then your tweets started getting
really good because your internal
thinking got really good the gum road
thing itself i think that's the scar
tissue that you have because gumroad
almost failed so for you you think it's
important that gumroad has to succeed
for you to be taken credibly just like
when gumroad was failing you thought
that no one was taking you credibly
neither of those were true i think you
were your own worst critic which is fine
that's what it takes for successful
entrepreneurs successful entrepreneur is
their worst their own worst critic um
but you could stop tweeting the gun road
financials tomorrow and i don't think
anybody care your credibility is not
derived from how gumroad is doing there
are a lot of people who are incredibly
successful financially who put out
tweets that are complete garbage
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you